bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition de
24h Sénat et on commence par le rejet du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2014 c'était aux
alentours de 13h15 le texte a été rejeté
par 189 voies contre et 139 pour la
Haute Assemblée a voté contre la 3è
partie du texte consacré aux recettes du
coup elle n'a même pas aborder la partie
dépenses on en parle avec notre
chroniqueuse Tam tranui alors bonsoir
Tam bonsoir Delphine ce n'est pas bien
une surprise hein mais il est arrivé à
l'issue d'un coup de théâtre hein ce
racontez-nous ce qui s'est passé
effectivement coup de théâtre et
psychodrame alors peu avant midi les
sénateurs poursuivent l'examen du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2014 et comme à leur
habitude depuis le début de la semaine
et bien il détricote soigneusement le
texte amendement après amendement on
s'achemine vers le vote et vers un
probable rejet final quand Marie
saltouren sort sa botte secrète alors
cette botte secrète qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est qu'elle demande une seconde
délibération un vote unique sur le texte
non pas amendé non pas complètement
bouleversé par les sénateurs mais sur le
texte du Gouvernement uniquement enrichi
des amendements du rapporteur donc un
texte avec lequel le gouvernement est
d'accord à 100 %. alors pourquoi A- eu
recours à cette procédure et ben pour
éviter tout simplement l'affronte de la
réforme des retraites c'était la semaine
dernière tout le monde a voté contre y
compris les socialistes parce que le
texte avait été tellement bouleversé par
les sénateurs qu'il ne ressemblait plus
à rien impossible même pour les
socialistes de voter pour et le verdict
donc a été très sévère 346 contre Z0
pour alors qu'en votant sur un texte
conforme au souhait du gouvernement la
ministre au moins s'assure du soutien
des voies socialistes des écologistes
seulement avec cette seconde
délibération Marie sal Touran s'est
assuré le courou de toute une partie des
sénateurs écoutez Chantal joano
sénatrice udi UC de Paris ce procéd pour
établir le texte tel que vous le
souhaitez je trouve est absolument
méprisant pour le Sénat il est méprisant
pour l'ensemble des sénatrices et des
sénateurs ici présents il est méprisant
pour les administratrices et les
administrateurs il est méprisant pour
les collaborateurs qui ont travaillé sur
ce texte pendant des heures qui ont
présenté des amendements on a eu des
discussions ici longues sur des
amendements il y a eu des votes et bien
tout simplement vous allez vous asseoir
dessus vous allez les
ignorer merci Tam pour ces explications
alors on a vu ambiance et bien tendue
dans l'hémicycle les sénateurs furieux
ont néanmoins dû se plier à la requête
du gouvernement et ils ont procédé à une
seconde délibération c'est ce que vous
allez voir tout de
suite madame le ministre mes chers
collègues la séance est reprise en
application de l'article 44 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution le Gouvernement demande
au Sénat de se proncer par un seul vote
sur les amendements qu'il présente et
les articles soumis à la seconde
délibération ainsi que sur l'ensemble de
la 3è partie du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 nous passons donc tout abord à la
seconde délibération conformément à
l'article 42 align 7 du Règlement nous
procéderons de la manière suivante je
demanderai au gouvernement de présenter
ses amendements je demenderai ensuite
l'avis de la commission des affaires
social et le vote sera réservé sur
chaque amendement et sur chaque article
soumis à seconde délibération madame la
ministre vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le Président le
gouvernement a souhaité rétablir
plusieurs articles dont j'ai dressé la
liste avant
l'interruption plusieurs articles de la
3è partie de ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 article qui avait été soit supprimé
par le Sénat soit substantiellement
modifié tandis que d'autres articles
avaient été créés alors certains d'entre
vous et surtout vous madame la sénatrice
joano avez parler de mépris il n'y a au
contraire qu'une volonté de transparence
de clarté
démocratique il est fort probable et je
ne peux que le regretter mais il est
fort probable sans vouloir anticiper sur
le vote qui va intervenir dans un
instant que le texte du Gouvernement
sera rejeté en tout état de cause donc
les amend
qui résulte de vos débats de nos débats
ne seront pas retenus et c'est
l'Assemblée nationale qui va reprendre
le travail ce qui serait ce qui serait
méprisant c'est de vouloir faire
procéder à un vote qui ne correspond pas
à la réalité de cet hémicycle en
revanche vous allez avoir l'occasion
d'exprimer très clairement votre
position ainsi que chaque groupe de
cette assemblée sur le texte proposé par
le gouvernement et il n'y a rien de plus
clair que de dire il n'y a rien de plus
démocratique que de dire dans le respect
strict de nos textes constitutionnels il
n'y a rien de plus clair que d'être
amené à se prononcer sur ce que propose
le gouvernement j'ajoute d'ailleurs
qu'il est assez intéressant et je suis
convaincu que l'opposition
gouvernemental il sera sensible que le
gouvernement fait le choix d'une
politique de maîtrise des dépenses
d'économie des dépenses que vos
amendements aboutissent à un surcût ou à
un accroissement du déficit de plus de 1
milliard d'euros et donc il n'est pas
totalement anormal que le gouvernement
alors qu'il subit les exhortations de
l'UMP quasi quotidienne à mieux
maîtriser les dépenses se pose des
questions sur la démarche qui a été
celle menée dans le cadre de ces débats
en tout cas nous avons la volonté de
présenter un texte qui dans ses parties
financières nous permettre de ramener le
déficit à un niveau inférieur à 13
milliards d'euros en 2014 je veux
rappeler que nous avons trouvé les
comptes de la Sécurité sociale dans une
situation de profond déficit avec plus
avec 21 milliards d'euros de déficit
nous proposons de le ramener en dessous
de 13 milliards ce que vous contestez
puisque le résultat de vos amendements
c'est que tout simplement nous
n'atteindrons pas ces objectifs et donc
plutôt que de nous donner des leçons sur
le déficit vous feriez mieux de mettre
en œuvre des politiques qui nous
permettent ENF par vos amendements qui
nous permettent d'aller dans ce même
sens la volonté du gouvernement c'est de
maîtriser les comptes sans en faire
peser la charge ou sans faire peser la
charge de cette maîtrise par sur les
épaules des assurés puisqu'il n'y a ni
des remboursements ni nouvelles
franchises dans ce texte nous proposons
au contraire des droits nouveaux et nous
proposons de proposer de de maintenir
les garanties que la nation apporte à
tous nos nos concitoyens au travers de
notre système de protection sociale
c'est le sens mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de la démarche du gouvernement
et c'est la raison pour laquelle il vous
demande d'adopter les amendements
présentés par le gouvernement et ainsi
que la trè partie du PLFSS pour 2014
merci Madame la Ministre quel est l'avis
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre mes chers
collègues la commission des affaires
sociales à la majorité à donner un avis
défavorable à l'adoption de ces
amendements
merci le vote est
réser je va donner la parole à
alors avant donc de passer au vote
unique portant sur les articles modifiés
par les amendements soumis à la seconde
délibération et l'ensemble de la 3è
partie du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2014 je vais
donc donner la parole à ceux de nos
collègues qui souhaite s'exprimer je
rappelle que lorsque le Sénat n'adopte
pas les dispositions de la 3e partie la
4e partie de ce projet de loi est
considéré comme rejeté la parole est à
Monsieur Milan monsieur le
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues je vais
dans un premier temps redire un petit
peu ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure à la
fin de la séance et d'une manière un peu
houleuse euh madame la ministre une
demande de ce délibération c'est déjà
intervenu et ça intervient
habituellement dans trois circonstances
la première c'est que soit le
gouvernement souhaite défaire grâce à la
majorité des absents ce que la majorité
des présents a adopté et ça concerne
généralement un ou deux articles soit le
gouvernement veut revenir sur une
disposition qu'il estime n'avoir pas
suffisamment expliqué et ça concerne
généralement une disposition soit enfin
il s'agit de rectifier des tableaux afin
de tenir compte des mesures adoptées et
ça à la rigueur c'est particulièrement
admissible donc c'est vraiment arrivé
avec le gouvernement précédent dans des
cas spécifiques et pour des cas
extrêmement restreints vous voulez quant
à vous aujourd'hui
rétablir des dispositions nombreuses qui
ont été rejetées par une large majorité
de circonstances parfois mais par une
large majorité quand même de cette
assemblée sachant évidemment qu'ils
seront à nouveau repoussés et on l'a
bien vu dans le cadre d'abord de la
commission des affffaires sociales et on
le verra tout à l'heure dans le cadre du
vote
général nous n'avons évidemment madame
la ministre pas changé d'avis sur toutes
ces mesures nous sommes évidemment
toujours opposés et je crois que si vous
mettez cela en place c'est pour
permettre au sénateurs de votre majorité
de pouvoir voter un texte plutôt que
d'être obligé de voter contre un texte
qui qui a été modifié par l'Assemblée
par l'assemblée du Sénat je dois dire
ici que cette
position nous surprend et nous peine
quelque part mais je peux la comprendre
à la rigueur puisqu'il ne restait en
fait et excuser ce mauvais jeune mot que
15 % du
texte je voudrais maintenant revenir sur
les les positions par rapport aux
mesures que vous avez
proposé nous avons proposé nous nous
nous sommes opposés à la hausse des
prélèvements sociaux sur les comptes
d'épargne car s'il s'agit bien d'une
hausse pratiquement 600 millions d'euros
nous nous sommes opposés à la clause de
recommandation d'un organisme de
provveillance par les branches
professionnelles déjà d'ailleurs écarté
par deux fois par le Conseil
constitutionnel et inter terne
acharnement à vouloir maintenir cette
position quelque part nous interpelle
nous nous sommes opposés au financement
des mesures prises en matière des
retraites complémentaires agricoes et
vous savez comme nous que le monde
agricole n'en peut plus nous nous sommes
opposés à la création d'une cotisation
des plafonnés d'assurance vieillesse
applicable aux affiliés au régime social
des indépendants et les indépendants les
artisans les commerçants manifestent
actuellement une manière extrêmement
importante contre toutes ces mesures que
vous êtes en train de prendre et que
vous avez déjà prise en 2013 nous nous
sommes opposés à la création de d'une
troisème tranche de la taxe sur le
chiffre d'affaires de la vente en gros à
la majoration du taux de la taxe
spéciale sur les conventions d'assurance
applicable au contrat complémentaire
santé dit nos responsables au mode de
calcul des cotisations dues par les
travailleurs indépendants nous voterons
évidemment contre ce texte madame la
ministre et nous voterons d'autant plus
contre ce texte que aujourd'hui par la
méthode que vous venez d'utiliser vous
mettez vous obligez vous mettez le Sénat
au garde à vous devant l'Assemblée
nationale
vous réintégrez les articles supprimés
par la majorité du Sénat vous supprimez
les propositions faites par le Sénat
même quand celles-ci sont venu de votre
camp pour nous c'est un dénis de
démocratie c'est un dénis du Sénat et du
bicabérisme et nous sommes encore plus
fortement opposés à tout
cela merci Monsieur Le
Men
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
comme je le soulignais en commission des
affaires sociales beaucoup de nos
collègues ont à propos de ce PF
généreusement labouré le champ des
regrets il est donc bon de rappeler
quelques éléments du contexte dans
lequel s'inscrit ce pfss pour nous
ramener un peu sur terre il y a un an la
loi de finance rectificative d' 2012 et
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2013 répondait à
l'urgence er la dérive des déficits qui
menaçaient la pérennité même du système
de protection sociale depuis le
gouvernement a réussi à atténuer le
déficit dans le contexte que nous
connaissons tous il faut saluer
l'exercice après un déficit moindre que
prévu cette année il devait il devrait
atteindre 16 milliards à la fin de
l'année la décru programmé doit ramener
ce déficit à un niveau proche de celui
d'avant la crise de 2008 le projet de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 que nous examinons depuis le début
de la semaine poursuit cette œuvre de
redressement en la faisant reposer sur
des réformes structurelles que d'cun
appelle à longueur d'onde et de médias
qui visent à moderniser notre système de
protection sociale et s'insccrive dans
une stratégie qui vise la croissance et
l'emploi après avoir engagé cette année
la réforme de deux branches retraite et
prestation familiales qui vont dégager
4,5 milliards de recettes nouvelles le
gouvernement nous propose de concentrer
nos efforts de redressement 2014 sur la
branche maladie la plus déficitaire ces
comptes sont en effet fortement dégradés
avec un déficit cette année qui devrait
avoisiner les 7,7 milliards on l'a déjà
dit tout au cours de ces de ces journées
soit 57 % du déficit du régime général
contre 44 % 2012 d'où l'effort
conséquent engagé en direction de cette
branche alors que les dépenses de santé
progressent de 4 % par an le
gouvernement entend ramener et il est et
c'est bien ainsi et qu'elle ne progresse
plus que de 2,4 % en 2014 l'objectif est
ambitieux et j'ajouteraiit courageux ce
pfess ne peut être lu qu'en cohérence
avec les réformes parallèlement mené ou
à venir la poursuite de l'objectif
d'équité fiscale dans le cadre du projet
de loi de finan pour 2014 l'avenir et la
justice de notre système des retraites
dans le cadre de la réforme engagée la
réforme de la politique familiale la
réforme de la prévention et de la prise
en charge de la perte d'autonomie à
venir ainsi que la loi de santé publique
ce projet engageant le déploiement de la
stratégie nationale de santé qui
préfigure la que qui préfigure la future
loi de santé publique les objectifs
affichés sont clairs
et je crois que il est bon de les
rappeler aussi après avoir abaissé le
déficit de 17,8 milliards en 2012 puis à
16,1 milliards en 2013 l'objectif est de
ramener ce déficit prévisionnel en en
2014 à 12, après des mesures de
redressement mais je le rappelle comme
je l'ai déjà dit en commission des
Affaires social qu'on ne peut construire
une politique active de solidarité
durablement à crédit si au-delà des
mesures figurants dans ce dans le pfss
le gouvernement va poursuivre avec les
partenaires sociaux la réflexion sur le
financement de l'ensemble de la sécurité
sociale ainsi grâce à l'ensemble des
réformes visant toutes les branches de
la sécurité sociale et à une réforme du
financement sur le quinquena la
réduction des déficits devrait se
poursuivre avec des comptes du régime
général qui frolleraiit l'équilibre en
2017 la démarche est cohérente la
démarche est organisée la démarche est
progressive pour la première fois elle
s'attaque à des réformes de structure
jamais osé auparavant notamment par ceux
qui nous critiquent avec véhémence voire
pour certains avec outrance aujourd'hui
et cette démarche porte l'espoir d'une
amélioration durable de notre système de
protection sociale c'est pourquoi le
groupe socialiste soutiendra avec
conviction et sans état d'âme ce pfss
ambie est courageux et votera les
amendements déposés par le gouvernement
merci Madame
Cohen monsieur le le président madame la
ministre je crois que ça a été tout à
fait
exprimé clairement par Dominique Vatin
avant la suspension de notre séance le
groupe CRC est
particulièrement triste et en colère
aussi de ce qui se passe dans dans
l'hémicycle et nous le regrettons
vivement nous assistons à un moment
grave dans une situation critique
politique où je crois que chacune et
chacun quel que soit le banc dans lequel
il se trouve rencontre aujourd'hui des
Françaises et des Français qui sont
particulièrement heurtés par les choix
qui sont faits par le gouvernement qui a
été élu il y a 18 mois parce que moi
j'ai pas envie d'avoir un débat dans
cette hémicycle pour savoir si la
procédure elle avait été adoptée déjà
par le passé ou non le groupe CRC a
toujours eu la même position
c'est-à-dire c'est toujours révolté
contre le dénis de démocratie et contre
le fait que le Parlement que ce soit
l'Assemblée nationale ou que ce soit le
Sénat soit privé de ces droits or nous
assistons à ce phénomène aujourd'hui
alors que nous avions eu des débats
certes qui pouvaient être parfois ouleux
mais des débats respectueux où pour ce
qui nous concerne au niveau de notre
groupe nous avons tenté d'apporter des
solutions différentes effectivement de
celles qui étai proposé par le
gouvernement mais parce que nous pensons
que dans ce pays il y a une majorité et
dans cette assemblée il y a une majorité
de gauche qui peut prendre des mesures
de justice sociale qui peut prendre
d'autres chemins que ceux qui sont
empruntés et que nous ne sommes pas nous
obsédés
je sais que ça ne plaît pas à tout le
monde mais c'est bien de le le dire et
de d'affirmer sa position chacun ayant
les mêmes droit ici nous ne sommes pas
obsédés par le fait de d'avoir une
maîtrise des dépenses et des comptes
quand cette maîtrise se fait au
détriment des besoins humains or avec ce
nouveau PLFSS c'est ce cheminlà qui est
emprunté c'est pourquoi les propositions
que nous avons faites ce sont des
propositions alternaat
et des propositions alternatives qui
sont des propositions de gauche pour une
vraie politique de gauche et la
responsabilité la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui nous ne
considérons pas que ce sont les
sénatrices et les sénateurs qui
emportent la responsabilité que le
gouvernement a recours à cette à ce
dénis de démocratie je dirais même à
cette mascarade
personnellement pour essayer d'échapper
à la situation qui a eu lieu
suite à la réforme des retraites je
trouve que c'est grave ça a été dit et
je trouve qu'il y avait d'autres issu on
aurait tout à fait pu et on pouvait le
comprendre continuer à travailler et à
aller jusqu'au bout du débat et faire
que le groupe socialiste refuse de de
participer au vote c'était une
possibilité et ça ne daignit pas les 3
jours de débat que nous avons eu dans
cet hémicycle qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que finalement nous avons
le droit au Sénat de parler nous avons
le droit de faire des propositions mais
à partir du moment où on est d'accord
avec ce que propose le gouvernement si
on n'est pas d'accord si ça remet
profondément en cause les choix qui sont
faits alors il faut qu'on se te d'une
façon ou d'une autre nos amendements que
nous avons essayé de
porter nos amendements que nous avons
essayé de porter jusqu'au bout que ce
soit au niveau de la de de notre
commission des affaires sociales et je
remercie la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales qui crée des
conditions dans un environnement
difficile pour que nous puissions
dialoguer et que nous puissions
construire mais à aucun moment il y a
des gestes d'ouverture pour qu'il y ait
une vraie coélaboration alors ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas admissible aujourd'hui
que d'entendre et bien c'est pas grave
et puis finalement c'est une bonne chose
le débat il a eu lieu circuler il y a
plus rien à voir et nous allons
l'Assemblée nationale va continuer à
travailler et bien non ça n'est pas
admissible donc ça n'est pas admissible
d'un point de vue démocratique au sein
de de de l'hémicycle ne soyons pas
étonnés que les Françaises et les
Français soient de plus en plus atterrés
par ce qui se passe et s'éloignent de
cette façon de faire de la politique et
donc je crois qu'il faut vraiment se
ressaisir il y a d'autres possibilités
de travailler ensemble il y a une autre
politique de gauche à promouvoir les je
n'ai pas le temps malheureusement de
décliner toutes les possibilités des bah
oui des amendements j'aurai d'autres
occasions monsieur le il y a pas de
souci et je je je je les prendrai ceci
étant dit on ne peut pas dire que tout
se passe bien et que finalement on a
fait attention au comptte de de la
sécurité sociale en préservant
effectivement les usagers quand on a
demandé suite à un oname ridicule
historiquement bas comme le dit un
ministre monsieur casazenu 440 millions
encore demander d'efforts aux hôpitaux
et bien quand on voit la situation des
hôpitaux partout sur tout le territoire
on ne peut être que catastrophé par ces
choix-là
merci Madame madame
archambau monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre chers collègues pour ce qui
concerne notre groupe écologiste nous
préférons et je l'ai déjà dit en
commission que le Sénat s'exprime sur un
texte cohérent or le texte qui sort des
débat à ce stade va dans tous les sens
et l'effet dévastateur dans dans
l'opinion publique du vote sur la loi
retraite qui qui qui n'a pas du tout été
compris
euh nous incite à proposer ce vote
cohérent c'est la première chose que je
voulais dire ensuite puisque c'est un
vote
bloqué je nous voterons aussi parce que
nous souhaitons que euh compte tenu des
procédures et du Règlement la 4e partie
de ce PLFSS puisse être débattu au Sénat
pourquoi parce que c'est dans cette 4e
partie et je pense qu'il faut sortir de
notre bulle c'est dans cette 4e partie
que que pourrait être pourront être
débatttu je l'espère des propositions
qui intéressent des millions de nos
concitoyens c'est c'est c'est toute la
politique de santé les dépenses c'est
toute la politique de santé qu'on peut
quand même débattre une fois par an dans
cet hémicycle me semble-t-il ça c'est
une exigence démocratique et il y avait
des il y a des amendements très
importants que nous avons présenté que
d'autres ont présenté et il y a un
consensus qui commençait à se dégager
d'une part sur des possibilités de
simplification drastique des procédures
ça concerne 10 millions de personnes
8600000 personnes qui dans ce pays sont
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté avec des
taux de non recours sur des droits très
importants un début de parcours de tiers
payant une une un développement de la
mobilisation contre les dépassements
d'honoraires une défense des des des
médicaments générique une défense de
l'hôpital public concrètement pas
seulement dans des slogans c'est tout ça
que nous espérons pouvoir débattre
démocratiquement au Sénat enfin je
voudrais dire puisque il y a un seul une
seule possibilité de s'exprimer je
voudrais dire aussi que nous autres
écologistes après le débat au stade où
nous en sommes et notamment après le
débat sur la troè partie dépenses nous
sommes inquiets et déçus nous avons été
nos propositions ont été très peu
entendu nos propositions en matière de
santé environnementale et de santé
publique à part quelques amendements sur
le
covoiturage des amendements qui étaient
pourtant raisonnables importants même
s'ils ont fait sourire parce qu'ils
correspondent à des changements de mode
de vie dans cette société parce qu'ils
correspondent pas seulement à des exigen
environnemental parce que si nos
concitoyens veulent pouvoir utiliser le
vélo et il y a des chefs d'entreprise
qui seraient prêts à développer ça il y
a aussi des chefs d'entreprises de ce
point de vue-là et bien c'est important
quand même donner la possibilité légale
non pas les contraindre mais la
possibilité légale aux chefs
d'entreprise qui veulent encourager les
bonnes pratiques en matière de transport
c'était tout à fait raisonnable pourquoi
est-ce que ça n'a pas été entendu sur
l'huile de palme il est avéré qu' qu'on
cèe nous raconter des histoires il est
avéré que que ce type de grèe est très
dangereux pour la pour la pour la santé
publique et c'est la même chose sur le
diesel où l'opposition entre réussite
économique emploi et santé
ne tient pas quand on sait et les études
sont sérieuses que les particules fines
le diesel c'est 10 à 20 milliards de
coût pour la sécurité sociale alors
encore une fois la politique de
prévention c'est toujours pour l'année
prochaine c'est jamais le bon moment
pour l'enclencher concrètement et nous
sommes toujours dans une nous gardons
encore très prignante une culture
politique de la de la politique de santé
réparation réparation des dégâts on
attend qu'il y ait des victimes et des
et des et de très nombreuses victimes
pour enfin réagir et réparer et de ce
point de vue-là nous avons joué notre
rôle d'initiative parlementaire je ne
comprends pas pourquoi il faudrait
attendre un projet de loi que nous
attendons tous bien sûr on peut
enclencher les parlementaires ont le
droit d'aller ont le droit et le devoir
et le devoir d'exercer leur
responsabilité d'alerte donc nous sommes
très soucieux parce que nous sommes très
soucieux des équilibres sociaux et
effectivement de diminuer le le déficit
de la Sécurité sociale toutes les
propositions que nous allons nous avons
faites tout ce qui est de
l'investissement dans les politiques de
prévention de santé vont dans le sens de
faire faire des économies colossales à
la à la à la sécurité sociale et à la et
et à l'Assurance Maladie ce signal n'a
pas pu être donné à l'opinion publique
par le Sénat c'est vraiment dommage et
et je pense que vraiment il y a un
problème dans dans dans dans ces débats
de plfsr on oppose les finances à la
santé ce n'est pas parce qu'on parle de
finance d'exigen financières et
d'exigigen de faire des économie et de
rétablir les comptes publics qu'on ne
doit pas parler de santé parce que
investir dans la santé et dans la
prévention c'est faire des économies
nous sommes au cœur du sujet quand nous
parlons de la prévention nous sommes au
cœur du sujet qui est de réduire les
déficite de la sécurité
sociale merci madame monsieur
Savari
oui merci monsieur le Président pour
souligner également ma ma ma déception
par rapport à à cette procédure où nous
avons travaillé au sein de la commission
des affaires sociales de long moment
nous avons travaillé jour et nuit depuis
cette semaine de long moment également
pour arriver à faire des propositions
des modifications qui certes sont pas
acceptables sur l'ensemble de ces ban
mais qui contribuait à une volonté de
maîtriser les dépenses et d'être
attentif à la santé de nos concitoyens
mais également être attentif à la partie
médico-sociale alors soullignez madame
la ministre que vous avez une attitude
très circassienne vous faites de la h
voltige je dirais en ce qui concerne
l'explication de cette procédure de vote
bloqué mais qui ne va pas dans le
sens me semble il d'une véritable
maîtrise fiscale mais plutôt d'une
véritable méprise sénatoriale et c'est
je crois un élément fondamental de
l'attitude qu'on a pu constater sur les
bands de ce gouvernement depuis ces 2
jours et 3 nuits que nous sommes 3 jours
et de nuits que nous sommes ensemble où
on a l'impression que il y avait
véritablement pas d'écoute à des
propositions qui pouvaient être faites
que l'on ait des débats critiques
parfois c'est tout à fait justifié mais
à travers cela il y avait des
amendements qui étaient tout à fait
intéressants en tout cas les amendements
qui ont pu aboutir jusqu'à notre
hémicycle puisque un certain nombre
d'amendements ont reçu une
irrecevabilité sociale ou une
irrecevabilité financière contestable
puisque certains étaient présentés de
façon identique l'an dernier ils étaient
acceptés présentés aujourd'hui ils sont
irrecevables donc je crois que il faudra
qu'on travaille également là-dessus en
tout cas c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous confirmons notre vote quel que soit
les tergiversations que vous nous avez
présenté merci Madame
Dini merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je ne vais pas revenir sur
le scandale de du vote bloqué madame
joanau s'est exprimé pour notre groupe
et nous partageons aussi le
l'indignation des collègues de nos
autres groupes je vais euh par contre
donner notre avis sur cette troème
partie vous ne serez pas étonné que nous
soyons totalement hostile à ce volet
recette l'ensemble des dispositions
qu'il propose nous semble insupportable
en particulier d'abord pour nos
concitoyens je vais reprendre
quelquesunes des dispositions que vous n
que vous avez proposé taxation des
produits de placement élargissement de
l'assiette des revenus agricoles dé
plafonnements partiel des cotisations
vieillesses des artisans et comm
pardon création d'une contribution sur
les boissons énergisantes majoration de
la taxe spéciale sur les conventions
d'assurance ce PLF SS poursuit la
logique de la fuite en avant fiscale pas
de pause fiscale en matière sociale plus
de 4 milliards de taxes prélèvement et
impôts nouveaux des recettes aussi
problématiques quant à leur nature même
on ne comprend pas le détournement des
réserves du fond pour l'emploi
hospitalier au profit de la CNRACL dans
le Palma reste des recettes
problématiques la taxation des produits
de placement refondus par l'article 8
même réduit au seul contrat d'assurant
de vie multisport multisupport pardon
figure évidemment en en bonne place et
surtout nous ne pouvons absolument pas
accepter la prorogation de la
confiscation de la Casa la Casa a été
créée pour financer la dépendance en
l'absence de réforme de la dépendance
son produit est indirectement fléché sur
le FSV et c'est totalement
incompréhensible en effet fait elle
devrait servir au minimum à compenser le
coût de la pas aux départements qui ont
de plus en plus de mal à en assumer la
charge l'importance des recettes de
transfert est aussi un signal très
inquiétant via le PLF vous transférez 3
milliards de recettes de l'État par
l'affectation à la sécurité sociale
d'une fraction supplémentaire de TVA
dont seulement 2 milliards de recettes
nouvelles puisque le dernier milliard
compense la baisse de la cotisation au
titre de la branche famille décidé en
compensation de l'augmentation de la
cotisation retraite c'est considérable
et c'est surtout un tel mélange des
genres que nous n'y comprenons plus rien
cela témoigne en tout cas d'une absence
de vision globale inquiétante et d'un
refus de s'engager sur la voie d'une
réforme structurelle cohérente du
financement de la protection sociale
nous ne pouvons pas non plus accepter le
rétablissement de la clause de
désignation alors qu'elle a été censurée
par le Conseil constitutionnel voici que
le gouvernement l'a réintroduit au
détour d'un amendement de PLFSS en
article additionnel histoire de faire
l'économie d'une étude d'impact les
mêmes causes produisant les mêmes effets
nous ne voyons pas en vertu de quel
miracle l'article de ne serait pas de
nouveau censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel comme portant atteinte à
la liberté d'entreprendre et à la
liberté contractuelle je ne j'aurais
encore beaucoup de choses à ajouter et
il y en aurait eu certainement beaucoup
sur le le volet dépenses mais et bien
évidemment pour déjà les raisons que je
viens d'indiquer en ce qui concerne les
reces
le groupe udiuc ne votera pas la 3è
partie du PLFSS consacré à ses recets
merci Madame madame
meunier madame la ministre chers
collègues j'ai l'impression comme
beaucoup d'autres ici que nous sommes en
train de revivre ce que nous avons vécu
lors du débat sur les retraites et là il
n'est pas acceptable il n'est pas
imaginable que le Sénat rejette la
partie recette de ce projet de loi qui
pose les fondations du redressement des
comptes sociaux il faut en effet que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités
dites-vous et nous allons les prendre en
ramenant en 2014 le déficit en dessà de
13 milliards d'euros très bien nous
soutenons le gouvernement qui depuis un
an redouble d'efforts pour préserver un
haut niveau de protection sociale pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyennes et nos
concitoyens nous savons que la situation
n'est pas facile mais nous ne voulons
pas succomber à l'idée selon laquelle en
période de crise il faudrait euh
sacrifier nos droits sociaux et renoncer
à notre modèle nous sommes déterminés à
faire et déterminés à construire
regardeer le chemin parcouru en quelques
mois il n'est pas mauvais d'avoir de la
mémoire souvenez-vous de la situation
que nous avons trouvé en regarde des
leçons que vous nous avez donné ici dans
cet hémicycle tout au long de ces débats
vous oubliez de rappeler qu'entre 2002
et 2012 vous n'avez pas été capable
lorsque vous étiez au gouvernement et
que la situation économique était un peu
meilleur de réduire les déficits et tout
en multipliant une série de franchises
vous avez au contraire laissé déraper le
déficit de la Sécurité sociale et vous
prétendez ici nous donner des leçons et
ne pas voter un texte qui justement
réduit le déficit la partie recette que
nous venons d'examiner propose des
réformes structurelles dans un cadre
respectueux de l'équilibre indispensable
entre les différents composants il
renforce l'égal et juste accès aux soins
en préfigurant la médecine du futur il
donne un souffle nouveau pour
réorganiser et améliorer la prise en
charge de nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyennes qui sont faut-il le
rappeler au cœur du système les l'examen
de ce projet de finance de sécurité
sociale est l'un des moments les plus
importants de la vue démocratique et
l'on donne sens au mot
responsabilité la responsabilité mes
chers collègues c'est de ne pas
transmettre nos dettes aux générations
futur c'est le moment où nos convictions
politiques prennent corps les nôtres
sont à gauche pour le progrès et la
justice c'est pour toutes ces raisons
que nous voterons la partie recette de
ce projet très bien monsieur cafet
bravo Monsieur café vous avvez demandé
la
parole monsieur le le
président peut-être sommes-nous à un
moment de vérité politique et en tout
cas c'est à travers ce prisme que
j'analyse
la véhémence des propos qui ont été
tenus maintenant et avant la suspension
de séance lorsque le gouvernement a
annoncé qu'il voulait procéder à une
deuxième dé
libération pour ma part je n'ai pas le
sentiment d'être méprisé par le
gouvernement mais pour ma part j'ai
plutôt le sentiment qu'une
conjonction une coalition
hétéroclite avec des motivations
peut-être
différentes cherche à faire échec au
gouvernement de manière systématique
c'était le cas sur la réforme des
retraites et qu'avons-nous observé sur
la réforme des retraites pas un
détricotage du
texte une succession une vague
d'amendements de suppression qui visait
à vider la réforme des retraites de tout
son contenu
tout
qu'observons-nous
aujourd'hui dans la discussion sur les
recette de ce
PLFSS exactement le même
phénomène ce n'est pas vrai madame mais
et puis écoutez je vous ai interromé je
vous ai inter je ne vous ai pas
interrompu madame joanou je vous ai
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention donc je
vous en prie ayez la courtoisie de me
rendre l'appareil et je vous le répète
moi je ne me sens pas
méprisé et donc c'est la même chose sur
ce PLFSS Ctait d'ailleurs la même chose
en fait sur le plsf le PLFSS pardon de
de l'an dernier et le le la discussion
budgétaire de de 2013 et donc je ce que
je dis c'est que une coalition
hétéroclite vise à faire échec au
gouvernement je me demande même si cette
coalition htéroclite ne cherche pas
l'échec du gouvernement mais un échec
global pas un échec sur un
texte et c'est ça que j'appelle un
moment de vérité politique et c'est
cette situation qui m'interroge
oui
bien alors dans ces
conditions madame Cohen excusez-moi mais
vous avez suggéré que notre groupe fasse
ne prenne pas part au vote bon
excusez-moi mais jusqu'à preuve du
contraire mon groupe est tout à fait
libre de déterminer comment il vote et
notamment les textes du gouvernement
donc vous comprendrez que nous ne
retenons pas votre suggestion
deuxièmement madame Cohen toujours
excusez-moi dans cet hémicycle personne
je dis bien personne n'a le monopole des
politiques de
gauche j'ai entendu parler hier par
exemple ah ce qui
m'a pas stupéfait mais quand même un peu
surpris et venant de de vos bancs de la
nécessité de remettre en cause le pacte
de stabilité et de la nécessité pour la
France de sortir de ce pacte de
stabilité
ce sera là poser un acte aux
conséquences
incalculables et je vous pose la
question la France doit-elle sortir de
la zone euro la France doit-elle sortir
de l'Europe est-ce qu'on me mais écoutez
c'est j'ai c'est ce que j'ai c'est ce
que j'ai entendu c'est la raison pour
laquelle c'est la raison pour laquelle
je vous dis c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous dis souffrez que nous
ayons des désaccords qui sont des
désaccords de fond et pas simplement des
accords de procédure et que vous
n'incarnez pas
à enfin je consacrerai le temps qu'il me
reste la petite minute qu'il me reste
bon à tracer les grandes lignes de ce
qu'est ce
PLFSS peut-on ignorer le l de la droite
les 160 milliards de dettes que nous a
légué la droite de 2002 à
2012 faut-il tenter de rétablir compte
de la de la protection sociale j'avais
dit l'an dernier que notre protection
sociale et je le répète était malade
qu'elle était malade de ses déficits
qu'elle était malade de sa dette et que
c'était la question de la pérenité même
de notre modèle de protection sociale
qui était en cause deuxièmement mais
comment voulez-vous comment voulez-vous
ouvrir de nouveaux droits et nous aurons
en 2014 l'année prochaine la discussion
sur le projet de loi sur l'indépendance
comment voulez-vous ouvrir de nouveaux
droits au à nos concitoyens si nous
sommes rigoureusement incapables
d'honorer ceux qui existent déjà c'est
ça la question fondamentale qui nous est
posée et par ailleurs enfin je le répète
y y a-t-il une seule atteinte aux
assurés sociaux dans ce PLFSS il n'y en
a aucune voulez-vous que je rappelle la
litanie des décisions qu'a pris la
droite de 2008 à 2012 tous les ans tous
les ans une remise en cause des droits
désassurés est-ce que c'est le cas
est-ce que c'est nous est-ce que c'est
ce que nous constatons il faut concl mon
cherè voilà je dis que ce PLF SS c'est
un PLF de gauche et que c'est parce que
nous sommes de gauche que nous que nous
refusion toutes les aventures merci
madame la Présidente Annie David et nous
passerons au
vote monsieur le Président je vais
essayer de dépassionner peut-être les
choses et et regretter à mon tour
néanmoins cette procédure accéléré parce
que le travail fait par notre rapporteur
général je regrette qu'il ne soit pas
repris par madame la ministre dans
l'ensemble
des amendements qui nous sont proposés
puisque notre rapporteur général avait
quand même déposé un certain nombre
d'amendements suite au travail qu'il a
fait d'audition et qui a un vrai travail
de fond sur le texte qui n'était pas des
amendements qui je crois voulaiit porter
atteinte à la réussite de ce
gouvernement comme je viens de
l'entendre et qui avait obtenu la
majorité et le vote de notre commission
je regrette pour ma part que ces
amendements n'est pas été adopté je
rappellerai d'ailleurs à ma collègue
Aline archambau que les amendements
covoiturage ne sont pas dans la version
que nous allons voter donc ils ont
disparu ils ne sont pas dans le ils ne
sont pas dans le texte qui va être voté
donc c'est un peu dommage là aussi que
ce vote bloqué ne prenne pas en compte
par exemple de l'article 10 B que nous
avons adopté suite à un débat intense
ici même concernant les le travail à
domicile d'ailleurs la commission des
affaires sociales s'est saisie de ce
sujet puisqueune mission va être mise en
place pour
pouvoir aborder ce sujet dans son
ensemble parce que en effet fait suite
au débats que nous avons eu hier au soir
et et et précédemment nous nous sommes
bien rendus compte que dans le travail à
domicile il y avait des des des des
difficultés à à à
à à résoudre pardon donc voilà je trouve
je trouve dommage pour ma part que tout
ce travail fait n''est pas été entendu
par le gouvernement pour le moins les
amendements que notre rapporteur nous
avait présenté et qui sont vraiment le
travail le vraiment le travail qu'il a
fait suite au à l'ensemble des auditions
et il y en a eu un grand nombre donc de
mon point de vue la commission des
affaires sociales malgré tout n'est pas
n'est pas véritablement reconnue pour le
travail qu'elle fait ici et je le
regrette profondément parce que nous
avons eu pas mal d'auditions pas mal de
réunions pas mal de travail fait et que
ce travail là non plus ne soit pas
repris madame la ministre je trouve ça
quand même très dommageable pour les
travaux de notre de notre hémicycle et
de la commission des affaires sociales
sans vouloir être plus longue parce que
je sais que nous devons passer au vote
je voulais néanmoins euh apporter euh ce
témoignage en tant que présidente de la
commission et avec tout le regret que je
peux avoir sur l'issu de nos travaux euh
qui va trouver une fin assez dramatique
je trouve dans ce vote bloqué merci
madame la Présidente je mets donc au
voix par un vote unique les articles
modifiés par les amendements soumis à la
seconde délibération ainsi que
l'ensemble de la 3e partie du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale en application de l'article 59
du règlement le scrutin public est des
droits et nous allons donc procéder à ce
scrutin
public le scrutin est
ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos et nous allons procéder
au
dépouillement
ah mais n on a
ou
résultat donc du scrutin 59 nombre de
votants 346 nombre de suffrages exprimés
328 pour l'adoption
139 contre 189 la 3 partie du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2014 n'ayant pas été adopté
la 4e partie de ce projet de loi est
donc considéré comme rejeté en
conséquent je vais mettre au voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 et nous allons procéder donc au
scrutin public qui est aussi de
droit
il faut
mettre mettre en place les
urnes
le scrutin est
ouvert
ne demande à voter le scrutin est clos
et nous allons donc procéder à son
dépouillement
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je donne lecture donc du scrutin numéro
60 sur l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 nombre de votants
346 nombre de supprages exprimés 328
pour l'adoption 139 contre 189 le Sénat
n'a pas adopté le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 madame la ministre vous avez la
parole oui monsieur le Président
quelques mots seulement pour regretter
que cette année encore nous n'ayons pas
la possibilité d'examiner dans cet
hémicycle les dispositions relatives à
la politique de santé à la politique
familiale à la politique en direction
des victimes d'accident du travail de
maladie
professionnel je le regrette mais je
prends acte du vote qui montre bien
d'ailleurs que le choix du gouvernement
était un choix de clarté de transparence
qui a permis à chacun d'exprimer euh ses
positions vis-àis des propositions que
fait le gouvernement puisque nous sommes
arrivés au terme de ce débat je voudrais
saluer la très grande qualité du travail
du rapporteur général et le remercier
pour son soutien son engagement et les
propositions qu'il a pu faire même si le
gouvernement ne n'était pas
nécessairement d'accord avec l'ensemble
d'entre elles mais euh je tiens à
souligner la très grande qualité du
travail qui a été mené par le rapporteur
général par l'ensemble des rapporteurs
et remercier madame la Présidente de la
manière dont nous avons pu travailler
ensemble et l'assurer que le
gouvernement est toujours très attentif
à la qualité des travaux menés dans sa
commission euh quel que soit l'issue des
débats que nous pouvons avoir et euh
j'espère que nous trouverons l'occasion
un jour de débattre sous une forme ou
sous une autre des choix du gouvernement
euh sur le fond de la protection sociale
car les questions de financement ne sont
que des moyens pour pouvoir garantir à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens une
protection sociale de qualité merci
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je vais suspendre la séance après avoir
remercié en votre nom à tous les
administrateurs du compte-rendu qui ont
accepté cette prolongation la séance
donc est suspendue elle sera reprise
voilà vous venez de suivre bien le rejet
du projet de loi de financement de la
Sécurité sociale on y revient tout de
suite dans 24h Sénat le
journal